hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of talking Germany
the show where we do just that now where
earlier this year Germany of course won
the football world cup for the fourth
time no less and after what was a
relatively short break the Bundesliga
one of the best leagues in the world is
now back in action so it seems like a
good time to talk about football and its
significance and much else besides with
a legendary football commentator here in
Germany here he is in person money
bright man thank you very much for
joining us here and talking generally
today ala Peter great to have you here
now wonderful now Matt mani bright man
can look back on a 36-year career as a
radio reporter and commentator during
which time much changed in the game but
not everything it is still the case that
as the former England captain Gary
Lineker once put it football is a simple
game 22 men chase a ball for 90 minutes
in at the end the Germans always win
it's a good quote isn't it it's a good
quote but it's not sure exactly not true
they don't always win yeah but of course
not very long ago into line in Rio they
won one nil in the world cup final
against Argentina with that wonderful
goal from Mario götze and did the German
team deserve to win I saw the match
against of gel jury Algeria Algeria as
usually Algeria okay it was so bad yeah
and nobody could imagine that this team
exact the same team would win the
championship but then you remember the
match against Brazil yeah semi-final
sistering one historic isn't Oracle 71
and then I was confident that they could
manage it and they did it in 1990 yep
against Argentine to first eleven and
two thousand and they repeated in a save
the same score in each case tell me this
what does what does the way that the
German national team plays soccer tell
us about Germany as a country in a
society
when you watched German football in the
80s or in the 90s it was working
football it was strong football it was
defense football and now they play
sometimes they play like Brazil did 20
years ago but they have a strong defense
to it is a combination between both
things I have always said that that I
won't compare football to the society or
to some development to the society
somebody told that in the 70s the way
they played football in Germany had
something to do with the students
rebellion oh that's that's too far they
the terraformer from that you think
that's too far-fetched I'm not so sure
I've been the way the way the great
dutch team of the of the 1970s for
example played football had a lot to do
with liberation in society nor did it
not for well to tell exactly volunteer
yes it may be that this is true but but
you can't say that the society in the
netherlands nowadays is no more free
they went one or two steps back but if
you compare it to the german society it
is free now ok I'm I'm gonna leave you
with that for now and I'm going to pin
you down a little bit bit we're going to
talk about German society and German
football and the interaction between the
two because I think there is something
going on there but you might disagree we
shall see just before we watch a report
about who you are and a little bit more
about who you are just tell me where
your passion for football first came
from from my father it's always the same
is it always is i'm not from my mother
certainly but from my father yeah i went
to the football ground in my hometown
with my father the well-known club
germania dutton everybody knows in the
whole world in the 60s they play in
green and white and they were champions
of Westphalia well 1961 and you were
there
later I changed to schalke no fear okay
that's you you upgrade it yes okay
go like teen I are wonderful I've always
wanted to do that on air and now I've
done it I've done many things in my
journalistic career but I've never done
the goal Oh thing I think the Spanish
commentators or the Brazilian
commentators they explode and could you
do that could you do a really long one
yeah yes a solidarity la derecha oh
brazil wonderful yeah he alive on
talking Germany great um let's go back
into your I've a look at your career
little bit and one of the one of the
things that it's important to mention is
that you were a radio man what's the
difference between radio commentating
and TV commentating soccer yeah more
words come out of your mouth yeah and
you have not to be such an analyst like
the TV commentator you are specialist
for the mood yeah for for what is going
on in the stadium yeah for the extent
yeah you have to describe most yeah to
describe more detail really yes and it
is very important that you described hmm
that you do not throw around with
statistics or so must describe what
happens on this green gram reliably
correctly accurately yes okay beyond
that you were also cult status as the
voice of the Ruhr Valley yeah what did
that mean to you cult status is is
modern it doesn't count so much for me
I'm popular okay it's alright but in the
70s you never would have said that I
have cult status they know me and it is
quite a lot to do with the fact that I
am sitting there I've been sitting there
for 38 years yeah but but the rule
Valley is everybody in Germany knows a
lot of people outside Germany is
associated with people who work hard
with a real traditional working-class
tradition you came from or did you I
mean would you say you came from a
working-class family no I'm not from a
working-class my father was a postman oh
so that sort of higher up in the lower
middle class or what lower lower middle
class but we have nothing to do with all
the coal miners
around us but data on the town where
came from yeah was a coal-mining town
but my my father and my relatives were
in the middle class but not not in the
upper middle class in the lower middle
class yeah it's interesting though you I
mean you do you you were special in your
family because you went away to study at
university first one first one it says
well whether you went away to study law
mm-hmm you didn't become a lawyer no I
didn't I didn't I've been after I have
studied law I've been to the government
I'll German government the person
information office under the door and
bit of a civil servant yes Helmut
Schmidt was a chancellor at that time
and Klaus bullying was the boss of the
information office that I've been there
for three years it rises there so that's
an interesting time but there was a very
may the seventh nineteen seventy-two was
a very important day in your life yes it
was my my first my first event on the
radio the first time I spoke into a
microphone I was so nervous you nervous
I smoked 50 cigarettes that day and from
then on it went on yeah but on a very
low basis in the first years and that
led to the point that I didn't stop
studying law I went on starting your
arms open yes yes yes I did it to the
end and my first world cup tournament
after ten years I had to be very patient
let's see but let's go back to that very
1st game in 1972 the game must have been
the game I know I'm not you know I'm not
guessing the game was very very
different back then from now it was in
what ways significantly it was much
slower it was slower but it's not former
before my eyes that it was slower if I
should see it on TV I would realize this
mm it I if I look upon media I must
confess that there were only three or
four journalists it was a second job
division that match I had bottom side
against noise noise yes little Rhineland
second division two thousand spectators
have been there and only three or four
journalists nowadays it would be brought
live on TV on a pay channel yeah on Sky
pay channel and there should have been
10 or 15 journalists watching this match
that's the main difference I see okay so
media coverage that that was where you
started what was the war in your career
what was the biggest match that you ever
did the commentary on the biggest match
was a world cup final two thousand to
Germany anal too thin in yokohama
germany played against brazil and oliver
kahn made those terrible mistakes
playing so blatantly in the clothes yes
and yes yes so I never cried out and
shouted out the words dodge slump is to
belt my staff and I did it never and do
you regret that a [ __ ] you would like
that out earlier did but I had the great
thing that within seven days to clubs
from the rural region got to the
european championship Schalke no fear
against Inter Milan UEFA Cup refs called
at that time and the Champions League
Borussia Dortmund against juventus turin
seven days later first in my lunch
milano and then in munich and I was on
the microphone and this was great for me
as a Rory we say okay and these days and
we talk about the difference between TV
and radio coverage these days if you
have the choice between listening to a
match on the radio watching a match on
TV what do you choose all the time on TV
on TV yes but you know sometimes when
I'm driving around in my car on a
Saturday afternoon and I listen to the
radio coverage it seems it seems richer
yes it's it's it's it's like theater
yeah and it's just dramatic and it's
good to listen to but if you have the
choice
world cup Metro so you're gonna want to
leave a brother it's a normal okay
well Manny broke man / I mean you know
what we've learned there is that
politicians like to associate themselves
with successful teams and successful
players in your in and you've been
involved in this book we're going to
present it that in a second that's one
of the topics you looked at what's your
position on all this I think quite a lot
of politicians like quite a lot of men
or women are interested in football but
quite a lot pretend to be interested in
because it's popular yeah and they want
to be popular and so they go to the
stadium's they present eight themselves
to the public Angela Merkel jumps off I
was going to say Angela Merkel was in
Brazil yes two longer if she was there
for the first game against Portugal yes
and then she was there for the final or
the final and you always think she takes
drugs before she goes to the football
stadium but but I think she's you can
say that about a chancellor she's
interested in football ah that's what I
was going to ask you a real or is she
phony in an emotional way I think st.
not very professional but in an
emotional way she likes to watch the
German national team yeah so thats its
real that's ok she is real yeah and she
was viewed at the World Cup recently as
a little bit of a sort of a good luck
kind of mascot for the team do you
really do you think she actually I don't
know what helped the team to triumph I
don't think so it looks good on the
bullet paper bulova yeah I had an
example of the governor of north and
west failure the later bundas president
johannes row ok he fairly a prominent
figure in German Polish a Social
Democrat he always said I'm a fan of bow
portales foul that's his hometown bapat
ah
but he was not interested in football at
all and I don't like this I don't like
this so he was a phony Angela Merkel is
not a phony she's real usually she is
real but not in a very professional way
okay no of course at the last at the
world cup of the world cup final angular
Merkel was there sitting right next to
her watching the final was set Blatter
mm-hmm a controversial figure in himself
yeah and then one seat down was letting
me a Putin yes I remember I remember as
sports and politics do have a
relationship or the politic look at the
winter olympics yeah and Saatchi yeah
and and look at the next world cup and
brush that's the point i mean the next
world cup is supposed to take place in
2018 in Russia should it Sepp Blatter
said some days ago that it will take
place in Russia now he's probably right
this this will not change I don't know
at this moment it's impossible to say
I'm not optimistic about qatar mmm 2022
Kansas 50 degrees are you for or against
do you think it was the right decision
to give it to her it was not the right
decision hmm it was a it was a decision
which had to do with mafia no nothing
else you said you don't much sort of you
don't have much truck with this argument
that politics and sports somehow mirror
each other but surely there are cases
where in Germany football has had a
positive impact on German society when
uh huh yeah maybe in 1954 aha in
Normandy in 1954 when Germany was down
on the ground yeah and they started
public life slowly the nine years after
the end of the war it was good for the
self consciousness of the German people
yeah yes ok so that's what that's one
example it was Germany's reintroduction
to the world stage in a way what a lot
of people here in Germany say is that
they look at the j
a national team now and they say they
see players like Mesut Ozil Jerome
Boateng Sami Khedira and many others
yeah who have got sort of there from the
Frog they grew up in migrant communities
immigrant communities here in Germany
great footballers fascinating people
they've done so much for German football
but they say the German national team
has done more than all the politicians
and all the media people up whoever have
done for integration in Germany that's a
sign for integration now I must I must
commit that this is a sign for
integration that measured Ozil place in
this team but it is normal it isn't why
sure why sure why should he not play
this game you have to get to the point
where it is normal and where people look
at it and say yeah yeah I remember when
gear out azam oh uh oh yeah as a first
black played in the international team
yeah some some looked but I mean
challenges for a long time Germany
struggled a real lot with these issues
with integration yes and these were
important watersheds yes football had a
very important purpose this is only a
little point it's only a little point
the main things happens in the town the
main main things happens on other places
but not on the football ground yeah you
have written a book that came out not
too long ago and it's it's interesting
because the book is it was discussions
that involved yourself yeah the the
soccer commentator Harold Schmidt a
satirist and in an entertainer orly her
knees former world champion now in
prison now in prison for tax evasion
yeah Claudia raw to a leading member of
the Green Party here in Germany yeah
what a combination of people yeah it's
interesting what what kind of
conclusions did you draw about German
soccer in your book and first of all I
thought it should be an interesting
thing to bring those different people
together yeah in my own flat yeah so it
was in your play we're sitting on my
sofa
a wife were so nervous when Ellis famous
people came there how entertaining
wonderful as and we talked six hours
yeah it was a very hot day in August
2012 and we talked about everything that
has to do with football ever talked
about fans we talked about media we
talked about violence we talked about
money and football six hours and then we
put this to that book and we made an
audio version 2 of this book yeah okay
we're just hearing in that report about
the fans about the shirts they buy the
scarves they buy and the flags day by
you you've got a story about her about
your own flag my own flag my first own
flag was made by my mother it was green
and white and you remember Joe Manya
Dutton germania Dutton grating Manya
duffel what's happened to that team
these days where are they these days Oh
six or 7th division ok they're still
existing though do you happen to know as
a football expert the average number of
fans who attend a bundesliga match I
think 43,000 really goes pretty good i
wrote down 42,000 but i might have been
up at the top end of 42,000 the average
number in spain average number in spain
should be a thing 28 also wonderful very
good yeah 21,000 in italy 35,000 in the
in the very moneyed very expensive
premiership in in England yeah so
Germany is is ahead they're more
expensive more expensive exactly why why
is Germany leading their white of all
fact with German fans attend matches
than any other top league we have the
modern stadiums that's the reason if you
compare it to Spain or even Italy Italy
this is bad with stadiums yeah that's
that's the reason and the entrance fee
is not so high how much do you pay to go
with an average bundesliga match these
days uh I think 22 or 25 on an average
20 to 25 euros yeah yes so it's over
twenty to thirty dollars or something in
that rates cheap really and it's
inexpensive it's not cheap yeah pretty
much anybody can go yeah we mentioned
that you came from the the working class
raw valley originally no is soccer still
a working-class sport no no Noah days no
more nowadays no more I realized that
people are going to the football
stadiums wouldn't have done this 20 or
30 years ago mmm it's not not so
basically working class this is also
something to do with the question where
is the
working class do you have the working
class the working class disappears yeah
it's interesting that you say that I'm
surprised to hear you saying that given
that you do you know you go to the you
go to see dortmund a lot you go to see
schalke a lot these are teams that sort
of cultivate this kind of drilling look
at the players look at that players hmm
they even don't come from we're working
class no they are middle class yeah all
the players most of the players we must
say a middle class yeah it's interesting
though here in Berlin our local football
team how to Berlin when I go there if I
stand among the sort of the ordinary
fans the cheap seats yeah what the seats
you're talking about I'm surrounded by
real very hard working men and women I
have the feeling with a real sort of
working class culture yeah that has a
test to do with the demographic
situation of some towns it may be that
in Berlin it sir yeah the I remember the
former Irish international a Manchester
United player Roy Keane very famous
player you you'll be very familiar with
he once said that there are too many
people eating prawn sandwiches at
football stadiums these days yeah is
that a problem in Germany are they I
mean is it becoming to the people
drifting too far away from the clubs and
the club culture it was a subject we're
all yonas always like to talk on yeah
the people in those lodges and dip stand
the area be areas they bring the money
yeah so that those people for eight or
ten euros can go to the stadium for such
a low price yeah you I know I mean you
don't like to talk about the fact that
you're in retirement and that is that is
well and good because you're not in
retirement you do an awful lot of your
very busy retire man is a word written
on a sheet of paper okay it's not the
reality of doing quite a lot you're
doing a lot yeah including writing
detective stories thrillers yeah but I
want to talk about one thing you
specifically do and that is you do a lot
of public speaking and one of the things
you speak on in public is how Bundesliga
club
and the Bundesliga is run financially
how the clubs are financed what can you
tell us there because I think there's
some very important lessons for other
leagues I think that the Bundesliga is
from the economic way in a good shape
yeah they have they are moved to 22
billion of euros every year and the
annual turnover yeah annual turnover and
not so much depth Singh 700 million
euros depth for all the Bundesliga clubs
so 7am how much again 700 million euros
700 million euros of debt yes miss Liga
clubs yes which is sounds like a lot but
compared to real madrid also has seven
exactly they got a conspiracy yes the so
the Bundesliga clubs are in total very
same yeah and how is that how if they
achieve that how are they how have they
managed to stay so healthy it has quite
a lot to do with the World Championship
2006 mm-hmm because at that time we got
the new stadiums or the renovated
stadiums and Germany and what this was
the basic this was the basic to build
this growth upon I think it is the most
important reasonable for this okay we
talked about that we talked we talked a
little bit about politics and money and
football teams being successful winning
tournaments or trophies or what have you
and the one team in Germany that that
brings all that together more than any
other is clearly Bayern Munich yeah
we're talking very optimistically and
positively bit about the Bundesliga but
does the Bundesliga have a problem with
Bayern Munich being simply too good BAM
Yannick is too good you must say this I
think that only borussia dortmund in a
certain way can compare itself to Bayern
Munich in the year after the World Cups
normally by muni
is not that good so they struggle a
little bit maybe that Borussia Dortmund
will be the champion of the Bundesliga
and the next year but Bayern Munich will
always be in the next 10 or 15 years you
can can make this prognosis under the
first two or three or even the champion
and the little clubs they don't have any
chance they always say in the Bundesliga
everybody every crime club can beat the
other that is no more true I think
you're right I think you're right on a
very good day a small club can beat bama
on a very very good day if by menu plays
bad okay
many broke my know what I really like
about that report is in the battle
between mama and Manny yeah I wow you
want not bad at all the beer there you
go doesn't work without beer how did how
did it come about that you got that job
as it were I'm doing football
commentating for the blind people I
really in nearly every football stadium
of the Bundesliga there are places for
the blind 15 or 20 blind I did not know
that 15 or 20 blind yeah they have
earphones are ya and some people who
like this in a mature way didn't make
the commentating and sometimes I'm the
guest yeah charcoal doremon go home just
low for cologne again there and so I had
the idea we could do this with the
carnival parade in this little off I was
commented at the carnival parade for TV
for 16 years and for radio another eight
or nine years and then I made this off
offered and they said okay well I guess
that that's very interest me awful lot
because I have it I have a friend in the
UK who's very well-known journalist in
the UK man called Peter white if it just
happens to watch the show he's blind and
when he is he writes a lot about in his
journalism about you know how easy how
he perceives the world it's very
interesting and when he visited me not
too long ago he said there's a football
match on I'd like to watch so we sat
down and we were watching the football
match and what did you do but what's it
yeah you see no commentary he can't
speak German and we were watching in
German because there was that was it was
German commentary IOUs yeah he can't
speak German and at some stage he said
the commentator got that wrong hmm yeah
and just from the acoustics of the what
was happening in the in the football
match he must have understood what was
happening better than the commentator
actually understood yeah it's
fascinating have no anila blend Blankman
who heard the acoustics and could say
this is Stuttgart oh well there you go
yes is Munich yeah this is Joker yeah
yeah we're getting slowly but surely
towards the the end of the show yeah my
golden micra like to ask our guests to
bring something up a prized possession
in this instance it truly is a prized
possession yeah you're golden microphone
tell us a little bit more about that it
was constructed by a listener yeah it's
not an official golden microphone but I
think it's very nice the 25th
anniversary of my microphone Korea in
the year nineteen ninety-seven yeah so
long ago then he made this present to me
I'm like it very much okay wonderful one
more thing I need to do before you go
you used to use to do have a friday
afternoon feature as i understand it
which was which was Manny against the
rest of the world where you would
forecast what was going to happen in the
weekend matches I've got you here on air
now and I would like to challenge you
I'd like to have i I'd like to go
head-to-head with you and I'd like you
and then I'll come back to you in a year
or twos time or at the end of this
season you predict who's going to win
this year's Champion's League and I'll
predict who's going to win the Champions
League this year this year's Champion's
League will be 1 by Real Madrid to once
again ok here on air you're going to
hear this for the very first time I
predict that this year's Champion's
League will be 1 by Liverpool Liverpool
I can tell you're astonished and don't
believe it what watch this space at what
you you know I I'm looking forward to
your telephone call when Ray I'll go out
some very impressive and very impressed
we normally have a quiz at the end of
the show and either all kind of a quiz
I've got a different kind of a quiz for
you I would like to know in your
estimation money Brightman legendary
soccer commentator who was the best
German soccer player of all time best
German soccer player of all time yet was
France Beckham bar I thought you might
say that yeah best german coach club or
international doesn't matter
best german coach wick wick I must speak
with your punk ass your bangers can buy
that who coached real madrid of course
yeah as well okay that's your lot for
this edition of talking Germany where
we've been talking football and much
else besides with the legendary reporter
and commentator Manny Brightman if
you've enjoyed his company as much as I
have then do come back next week until
then bye-bye and juice